donald trump received some of his best
polling in a while yesterday
there's a major new poll from cnn which
has joe biden
only four points ahead of donald trump
with the margin of error that could mean
trump is now straight up winning
this is one of the closest polls in a
while it's not
the only one that says the race is this
close but it should be
a huge warning to anybody who thinks joe
biden has this in the bag
especially if you thought yesterday's
first day of the dnc was not so good
then we have nothing to sit back and uh
be complacent about if we look at recent
national polls
cnn now has biden only plus four and
otherwise it's a bunch of biden plus
seven
biden plus nine biden plus ten other
than a harris x poll from a week ago
which agrees it's biden up by four
now if we look at this cnn poll more
closely
you will see that the margin of error is
3.7
okay so that means that
the poll says this is not speculation
instead of 50 biden might only have 46.3
instead of 46 trump could have 49.7 so
this poll if you read it correctly and
understand the margin of error
the poll says that right now trump could
be up by 3.4 now i don't need to remind
you
that in 2016 hillary clinton had a lead
of three
in the national polls and she ended up
winning by
two from the standpoint of the popular
vote and lost the electoral college as
michelle obama astutely pointed out
yesterday
this is a poll which says forget about
whether biden is
up three or four trump could be up three
nationally right now this poll
outlines a better situation for donald
trump today
than he had in november of 2016. now
it's one poll the average lead for biden
remains just under eight points but why
would we take any chance
the polling is looking more and more
like it did in 2016.
anyone thinking this is over needs to
check the facts and the facts are that
not only is the polling tightening
between biden and trump
trump's approval is climbing i i know
that
when we think about facts and reason
it is crazy to think that this would be
going on but we live in a country
where more than 60 million people voted
for the guy in 2016.
so we have to expect things that make no
sense and if you look at the gallup
trump approval tracking poll
you see that after a huge drop in
approval during the earlier phases of
the coronavirus pandemic
donald trump's approval has slowly but
surely
started to creep back up from a low of
38
back in uh whenever up to 39
40 42 and the trend is pointing
further up now we can debate why this is
happening
some people are falling for trump's bs
they're just falling for it
uh we have a crazy situation that has
been normalized to some degree
and people have gotten used to the
pandemic and used to
thousands of people dying every single
week from coronavirus
there are some people that are just dumb
okay oh fine that's some p
it doesn't matter that's the thing they
get to vote and we get to vote
our focus needs to be getting out the
vote
and making sure that we vote this is not
if if you looked at biden plus 15 in an
outlier poll six weeks ago and thought
this was going to be easy
this is not going to be easy this is not
going to be easy two and a half months
to go
we could see anything happen between now
and november
trump teasing he's going to pardon
someone major today
who knows what that is he mentioned he
said it's not snowden today
but he's now thinking about we don't
know how different
elements of the electorate could react
we have no control over it we only have
control over our voting
and talking to other people about the
importance of voting let me know where
you are
on this polling issue on twitter where
you can find me at deepakman
and remember that august 23rd is the
15th anniversary of the david pakman
show
on that very special day we will be
sending out
a coupon code via our newsletter
with an insane possibly illegal
certainly immoral membership discount
that you can take advantage of just get
on our newsletter
free at davidpakman.com if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video